je vous le disais dans les titres tout à
l'heure le littoral du languedoc
roussillon n'a jamais été aussi
fréquenté que durant cette première
quinzaine du mois d'août selon les
estimations qui sont faites le taux
d'occupation est de 100% 100% dans la
totalité des stations
alors on peut imaginer que les
professionnels du tourisme se frottent
les mains
il s'agirait de la meilleure saison de
la décennie il faut dire que beaucoup
d'efforts de promotion ont été faits
pierre bosc la presse la cohue les
embouteillages dès les premières heures
de la matinée c'est la ruée vers les
plages les routes littorales sont prises
d'assaut par des files d'automobiles
part au choc contre pare chocs la baie
de collioure n'est pas seul à connaître
ce grand rush de cerbère au grau du roi
la densité de population a plus que
doublé dans toutes les stations
oui cette année nous avons beaucoup de
membres d'elecam pin semble plaire
surtout sur le littoral 5 complet oui
même pas 4 à 5% entre encore quelques
places jusqu'au 15 août après le 15 août
l'incertitude plane une forte clientèle
d'étrangers oui une très forte clientèle
d'étrangers nous avons eu pour la
première fois dans notre département une
grosse clientèle de suédois et
norvégiens qui sont venus en force
l'année dont l'hôtellerie de plein air
camping et caravaning le point de
saturation n'est pas loin d'être atteint
les locations d'âge ans enregistre un
bond de près de 10% appartements et
résidences ont été loué en totalité dans
l'hôtellerie traditionnelle on affiche
également complet y compris oui jusqu'à
15 jusqu'au sage au 17 août 3 et après
savez sera naturellement ne se satisfait
de la saison
comme d'habitude j'ai toujours la même
le gars tu auras bien
il n'y a que la restauration pour faire
grise mine à cause des économies sur la
nourriture
une tendance qui se confirme un peu plus
chaque été par rapport à la dernière il
ya moins de monde c'est à dire comment
il ya tout le temps de monde sur les
plages mais n'en resteront pas d'argent
dans les prochains les gens consomment
moins en consommation ouais surtout en
restauration bar on travaille un petit
peu en restauration vaincre sa griffe à
dès la semaine prochaine leurs flux
touristiques devraient s'amorcer en
attendant les records d'affluence seront
ils battu en cette semaine du 15 août
il est encore trop tôt pour l'affirmer
une certitude le languedoc-roussillon
tient bien la côte d'amour